tonight about that suv involved in
today's crash in southern california
that left more than a dozen people dead
new pictures show the suv that it had
driven through a section of border wall
with officials telling fox news
the crash happened after a hole was cut
into the fence
a second vehicle had entered illegally
through the same hole but was stopped by
border agents 19 arrested in that case
the section of wall had been constructed
between 2007
and 2009 it's not part of the fencing
that was done
under the trump administration frankie's
nights
president biden moving up his timeline
for getting all american adults
access to a covit 19 vaccine
correspondent jillian turner reporting
on a busy day at the white house
regarding vaccinations
stunning projections on illegal
immigration and the implosion of a
cabinet
nomination a lot going on good evening
jillian it sure is a lot to unpack
shannon so president biden upped the
ante today in the battle against coven
19 he announced a partnership between
competitor pharmaceutical giants merck
and johnson and johnson
it's supposed to speed up the timeline
to vaccinate
every single american in a pretty big
way
we're now on track to have enough
vaccine supply
for every adult in america by the end of
may
he also rolled out a new directive named
at states which now must vaccinate
all teachers and school staff by the end
of the month he insists
this requirement will speed up the
process of reopening schools nationwide
with that done the white house insists
their main focus now
getting the president's coronavirus
relief bill passed in less than 12 days
when federal enhanced unemployment
benefits
run out but there's also another crisis
hurtling towards the president
when asked about a looming surge of up
to 20 thousand minors at the border
today
the president said this
[Applause]
the department of homeland security
projects that up to 117
thousand of them will cross the border
this year but press secretary jen saki
insists
they've got it handled we had the
secretary of homeland security yesterday
conveying it's a challenge
we're going to approach this without
labeling we're going to approach this
with policy
with humanity and with a focus on what
we can do to keep these kids safe
so far the administration is blaming the
surge on covet-related spacing
restrictions
and president trump who they accuse of
dismantling the immigration
system lawmakers on both sides of the
aisle now are sounding the alarm
all the good we did the last four years
to stop illegal immigration
is going to be damaged within months the
number of honor company kids the number
of
families are coming in are just
increasing every day
breaking tonight the president's nominee
to lead the largest office
at the white house that's management and
budget has withdrawn her nomination
in the wake of bipartisan opposition to
her nomination
nira tandon says she doesn't want to be
a distraction to the biden policy agenda
her decision though comes after weeks of
public scrutiny focused on her past
partisan attacks on twitter shannon
julian turner thanks for the wrap up you
bet